[Music]
thank you
in his essay on fairy stories J.R
Tolkien is going to devote an entire
section to what it's titled as children
and he's going to ask a central question
is there an essential connection between
children and fairy stories and to get to
the point he's actually going to say no
not really and he's going against the
prevailing opinion of his own time I
would say as well to some degree of our
our own time much later and maybe the
century before him as well and so he
starts out by saying that this is
actually falling under the scope of one
of the three questions he wanted to ask
what are the values and functions of
fairy stories now so if it's confined to
Children then the value of fairy stories
is really confined to those of that age
so he says it's usually assumed children
are the natural or the specially
appropriate audience for Fairy stories
and you know he criticizes those who say
things like this book is for children
from ages of six to sixty and children
you know Tolkien doesn't want us to
remain children at age 60. he thinks
that there's a problem with that and so
he says you know is there any essential
connection between children and fairy
stories is there any call for comment if
an adult reads them for himself he says
adults can study whatever they want but
what about reading fairy stories is that
childish is that immature and so in
examining this he's going to say there's
an error of false sentiment that winds
up being committed here and that's
because some people think that there's a
natural connection not just between
children and fairy stories but the minds
of children and fairy stories of the
same order of the connection between
children's bodies and milk you know
not everybody drinks some milk in
adulthood but children need milk to grow
and for their bones and all that sort of
stuff and Tolkien wants to combat that
he calls this false sentiment at best
and he says one that is therefore most
often made by those who for whatever
private reason tend to think of children
as a special kind of creature almost A
different race
rather than as a normal if immature
members of a particular family and of
the Human family at large and then he
points out another thing that's really
important
he says that the association between
children and fairy stories is a matter
of what he calls our domestic history
meaning that this is not something that
has been the case Forever This has
arisen historically and it's a matter of
how we understand children and homes he
says fairy stories in the modern
lettered world have been relegated to
the nursery as shabby or old-fashioned
Furniture is relegated to the playroom
primarily because the adults don't want
it and don't mind if it is misused it's
not the choice of the children which
decides this
children he says except in a common lack
of experience they are not one as a
class neither like fairy stories more
nor understand them better than adults
do and know more than they like many
other things they're young and growing
so they have strong appetites and so the
fairy stories as a rule go down well
enough he says but in fact not all
children and not all adults have a taste
for a fairy story some may never have it
as children or adults so this is really
important to point out as a preliminary
now he goes on and he tells us that it
is true that in recent times fairy
stories have usually been written or and
he puts this in a quote adapted for
children but so may music be or verse or
novels or history or scientific manuals
and then he tells us that this is a
dangerous process even when it is
necessary
so Tolkien is not a fan of producing
fairy stories that are sanitized that
are made safe for children in the way
that we might you know particularly
associate with Disney or with so many
other uh things as well you know we
could talk about boulderization meaning
taking a good story and then removing
the juicy elements from it so that
you're wound up with you know something
that's not the same story at all and it
loses a lot of its force a little bit
later on in this he talks about
um
it is true that the age of childhood
sentiment has produced some delightful
books
the Charming however to adults of the
fairy kind or near to it but it is also
produced and he's got this wonderful
phrase a dreadful undergrowth of stories
written or adapted to what was or is
conceived to be the measure of
children's minds and needs the old
stories are mollified or boulderized
instead of being reserved the imitations
are often merely silly pig wiganry
without even the Intrigue or patronizing
or deadliest of all
covertly sniggering you're offering this
to the children you're like these stupid
kids right and it's a sort of
patronizing that goes on he says I won't
accuse Andrew Lang of this but certainly
he smiled to himself and certainly too
often he had an eye on the faces of
other clever other people over the heads
of his child audience
so you know this is a
a real culture critique that Tolkien is
engaging in at this point and you know
we should talk about Andrew Lang so if
you're not familiar with who he was he
brought out this entire succession of uh
you know books about fairy stories and
they are all associated with particular
colors and it was quite popular at
Tolkien himself read him and he says
something very interesting about about
Lang to start with so he says
collections of fairies stories are by
Nature addicts and lumber rooms only by
temporary and local custom playrooms
their contents are disordered and often
battered a jumble of different dates
purposes and tastes but among them may
occasionally be found a thing of
permanent value an old work of art not
too much damage that only stupidity
would have ever stuffed away and then he
says Andrew Lang and his works are not
Lumber rooms
but what are they like stalls in a
rummage sale or what we might call a
flea market here in the United States he
says someone with a duster and a fair
eye for things that retain some values
been around the attics and box rooms
right so this is the person who
collected stuff from all these addicts
his collections are largely a byproduct
of his adult study of Mythology and
folklore but they were made into and
presented as books for children
and then he says you know let's think
about Lang's books so he's going to
criticize Lang at a number of points but
this is a critique that reveals
something positive as well
he tells us that the introduction of the
first of the series speaks of children
to whom and for whom they're told they
represent he says the young age of Man
true to his early loves and have the
unblunted edge of belief a fresh
appetite for Marvels is it true he says
is the great question children ask
Tolkien is going to consider each of
these in turn so the first thing belief
and an appetite for Marvels Tolkien says
Lang is confusing the two of these
they're being treated as identical or
closely related and then Tolkien says
these are actually radically different
though the appetite for Marvels is not
at once or at first differentiated by a
growing human mind from its General
appetite we all want Marvels wonders
things that are oh this is amazing right
that's not the same thing as belief
though so he goes on he says it seems
clear Lang was using belief in its
ordinary sense belief that a thing
exists or can happen in the real primary
world
now can happen that's possibility right
so to believe in something is to believe
that it was the case or is the case or
will be the case or that it is possible
for it to be the case and Tolkien goes
on and he says that
if this is true then I fear that Lang's
word strength stripped of sentiment can
only imply the teller of marvelous Tales
to Children must or may or at any rate
does trade on their credulity
the lack of experience which makes it
less easy for children to distinguish
fact from fiction
and Tolkien is treating this as if it's
like you know you're basically tricking
children with these fairy stories he
goes on and he says that children are
capable of literary belief when the
story Maker's art is good enough to
produce it this state of mind has been
called willing suspension of disbelief
we've all heard that phrase have we not
to talk about what happens with fiction
Tolkien says that's actually not a good
descriptor for what goes on what really
happens is what Tolkien says is that the
story maker proves a successful sub
Creator he makes a secondary World which
your mind can enter this is really
important for Fairy stories and for
fantasy for Tolkien inside what he
relates is true it Accords with the laws
of that world you therefore believe it
while you are as it were inside the
moment disbelief arises the spell is
broken the magic or rather art has
failed your back out in the primary
world again looking at the little
abortive secondary World from outside so
it's not a willing suspension of
disbelief so that we enter into the
story rather the craft of the
Storyteller creates a world that we do
enter into and for a while while we're
in that world while the enchantment
holds we believe it
and we see it as true and then if it's
not done well maybe we never have that
effect in the first place
now uh he's going to go on and he says
that
um
is it true is the great question
children ask they do ask that question I
know and it is not one to be rashly or
idly answered Tolkien himself had
children right but that question is
hardly evidence of unblunted belief or
even the desire for it more often it
proceeds from the child's desire to know
what kind of literature they are faced
with they want to know what kind of
story are we actually
telling here what does truth actually
mean and Tolkien thinks that children
don't have all of the concepts and words
to articulate this but that's what's
going on in there
he also criticizes laying for well let's
call it a certain Romanticism
of uh
the times before he goes on and he says
that I was one of the children who
Andrew Lang was addressing I was born
around the same time as the Green Fairy
book the children for whom he seemed to
think that fairy stories were the
equivalent of the adult novel and of
whom he said their taste remains like
the taste of their naked ancestors
thousands of years ago and they seem to
like fairy tales better than history
poetry geography or arithmetic and then
Tolkien says this is a wonderful line
what do we really know much about these
naked ancestors except that they
certainly were not naked right so we're
attacking several thousand years ago
we're not talking about ape people
wandering around scratching at
themselves you know maybe putting on a
little bit of skin from a pelt once in a
while no no
people were wearing clothing in the past
and they also were engaging in the sorts
of things that laying is saying oh you
know they had fairy tales as their
substitute they were not interested in
these other things and uh Tolkien says
that our fairy stories however old
certain elements of them may be are
certainly not the same as the people of
the distant past yet
if it is assumed that we have fairies
fairy stories because they did then
probably we also have history geography
poetry and arithmetic because they like
those things too and only somebody who
doesn't actually know the history of
ideas would say the sort of thing that
laying is saying here but it's kind of a
common idea isn't it
Tolkien also talks about moving away
from a focus on
possibility
and thinking instead about desirability
he says that for children of the present
day Lang's description does not fit my
memories or my experience of children
laying may have been mistaken about the
children he knew but if he was not then
at any rate children differ considerably
even within the narrow borders of
Britain and such generalizations which
treat them as a class or illusory I had
this is Tolkien telling us about himself
I had no special wish to believe I
wanted to know belief depended on the
way in which stories were presented to
me by older people or by the authors or
the inherent tone and quality of the
tale
and he says fairy stories were plainly
not primarily concerned with possibility
but with desirability
if they awaken desire satisfying it
while often wetting it unbearably they
succeeded and he tells us a little bit
about about what he was into you know he
didn't really care about Alice too much
Alice in Wonderland Treasure Island left
him cool as he said but the land of
Merlin and Arthur was what he was into
and best of all the nameless north of
Sigrid and the vulsings and the prince
of all dragons such lands were
preeminently desirable Tolkien says
so this is an important thing to attend
to as well and Tolkien tells us some
other things about his own taste which
are quite interesting I I find he says
that um
important as I now perceive the fairy
story element in early reading to Ben
speaking for myself as a child
I can only say a liking for Fairy
stories was not a dominant
characteristic of early taste a real
taste for them awoke after Nursery days
and after the years few but long seeming
between learning to read and going to
school
he goes on and he says that I also liked
a whole bunch of other things history
astronomy botany grammar and etymology
right uh poetry he said
um he was insensitive to and skipped it
if it came entails he only came to
appreciate poetry and Tolkien of
somebody who writes poetry when reading
Greek and Latin later on and he says
that a real taste for Fairy stories was
wakened by philology on the threshold of
manhood and quickened to full life
by War Tolkien fought in the first world
war and somehow that experience that
brutal experience that mature experience
that horrific experience
made him appreciate fairy stories
much more
there's another point that he makes that
I think is is very very interesting
which has to do with goodness and
Badness and justice
so skipping ahead a little bit he says
that I don't deny that there's a truth
in Andrew Lang's words even though
they're rather sentimental he who would
enter into the kingdom of fairy should
have the heart of a little child
he says well that possession is
necessary to all high adventure into
kingdoms both less and greater than
fairy but humility and innocence this is
what the heart of a child must mean in
such a context do not necessarily imply
an uncritical Wonder
right children can be very realistic
about this sort of stuff and even more
important nor indeed an uncritical
tenderness
Chesterton once remarked children in
whose company he saw metrolink's
Bluebird were dissatisfied because it
did not end with a day of judgment and
it was not revealed to the hero and the
heroin that the dog had been faithful
and the cat faithless and then
Chesterton says for children are
innocent in love Justice While most of
us are wicked and naturally prefer mercy
and then Tolkien goes on and says Andrew
Lang was really confused about this and
he tries to you know defend uh the
slaying of the yellow dwarf in one of
his stories and then um he goes on and
he says that here we go laying sends the
criminals as he boasts to retirement on
ample pensions that is Mercy on tempered
by Justice and what does Tolkien think
that children want they they want
Justice they want to know who's the good
one who's the bad one and they want to
know that not just because they need the
world divided up into black and white or
something like that their children can
actually have quite sophisticated moral
judgments
but they want there to be some sort of
Reckoning within the stories so that's
kind of an interesting point as well
it connects them with adulthood perhaps
and then finally Tolkien himself is
going to say that you know to answer
this question is there a central
connection between children and fairy
stories no there is not because they are
not just for children he says that if we
use child in the good sense it also has
legitimately a bad one we must not allow
that to push us into the sentimentality
of only using adult or grown up in a bad
sense it also has legitimately a good
one the process of growing older is not
necessarily Allied to Growing Wicked or
though they often do happen together
Children Are Meant to grow up not to
become Peter Pan's if you don't know who
Peter Pan is Peter Pan is an eternal boy
who you know takes some some children
out of our primary world into Never
Never Land and has all sorts of cool
Adventures but sooner or later we all
have to grow up we can't be Peter Pan's
it's that's actually bad for us he says
we don't have to lose innocence and
wonder but we have to proceed upon the
appointed Journey the journey into
adulthood into maturity right
he says it is one of the lessons of
fairy stories that on callow lumpish and
selfish youth Peril sorrow and the
shadow of death can bestow dignity and
sometimes even wisdom
and so he says you know
um we we need to think uh fairy tales is
something that should be read by adults
so he says if adults are to read fairy
stories as a natural branch of
literature neither playing at being
children nor pretending to be choosing
for children nor being boys who would
not grow up
what are the values and functions of
this and this is where we move into the
other topics so it's pretty clear that
Tolkien thanks fairy stories are not
primarily for children they are
primarily for human beings and those
human beings can be children they can be
adults and children should eventually
grow into adults the question is what
kind of adults they will grow into